Sorry, I'm late. I got stuck in traffic.
How long have you been waiting for?
Oh, that's OK. I just got here, too. Don't worry.
The cars were backed up for miles.
It was one of the worst traffic  jams I've ever seen.
Traffic is horrible during rush hour, and the traffic is bumper-to-bumper around this time.
That's why I always take the subway.
But aren't the subways also crowded during the rush hours?
It is, but it's faster. It's better than wasting your time on the road.
It'll take about 20 minutes on the road,..
..but it'll take more than an hour with traffic jam.
I guess you're right.
I can't believe people who drive in the city.
How can they do that every day?
And parking is so expensive.
How much is parking in Manhattan?
Oh, it is from 14 dollars to 30 dollars an hour depending on the area you park.
Wow, that's a lot. No wonder there are so many cabs in New York.